so auf lesbos herrschen nach dem brand
von moria immer noch dramatische
zustände
dafür hat sich diese woche unsere groko
gerettet die stand nämlich kurzzeitig
total auf der kippe wegen saskia esken
frau ascon hat sich am vergangenen
sonntag kurz aufgepumpt und der union
eine art ultimatum gestellt deutschland
holt eine hohe vierstellige zahl an
flüchtlingen oder es passiert was
passiert ist dann tatsächlich was immer
passiert wenn die spd droht nix nix die
sozen sehen sicherheit insgesamt heute
mehr im kunst- und happening bereich
13.000 leere stühle für die flüchtlinge
vor dem reichstag diese protestaktion
von flüchtlingshelfer ist erst einige
tage her die spd war mit dabei aha so
und ich dachte die leeren stühle werden
ein mahnmal für die bei der nrw-wahl
verlorenen spd-wähler deutschland holt
1553 anerkannte asylbewerber aus
griechenland klingt für den laien erst
mal wenig sind aber wenn man nach
rechnet 1553 mehr als der komplette rest
von europa holt unser innenminister
wollte er ursprünglich nur knapp über
hundert minderjährige aufnehmen
inzwischen ist mir eingefallen oder
müssen humanen notlagen reagieren und
können sagen jetzt war endlos ab es war
übrigens schon letzte woche meine
meinung wie ja bestimmt und wenn man
bedenkt wie lange er für diese
erkenntnis gebraucht hat kann ich nur
sagen ein glück dass heute nicht
feuerwehrmann geworden ist ja er ist
halt ausgelastet zum beispiel mit dem
verhindern von studien zu rassismus bei
der polizei niemand
niemand will nochmal unkontrollierte
zuwanderung wie 2015 aber ein bisschen
rest empathie darf man sich ruhig
bewahren angesichts der bilder aus
griechenland die eu guckt zu sie guckt
zu sogar wenn die polizei auf lesbos
verzweifelte menschen inklusive kinder
mit tränengas beschießt nach dem brand
wohlgemerkt kein wort dazu aus brüssel
oder berlin kein wort diese griechische
regierung ist gewählt worden weil sie
versprochen hat die zustände in den
lagern so furchtbar zu machen
keiner mehr kommen will manchmal teilen
sich die 160 menschen ein dixi-klo
tausende einen wasserhahn auf samos
haben die griechen sogar teilweise die
hauptwasserleitung abgedreht kein spaß
also nix gegen asyl entscheide an der
außengrenze aber man muss die leute dann
doch wenigstens menschenwürdig
unterbringen wenn wir noch im spiegel
gucken können will trotzdem wird athen
aus brüssel eigentlich immer nur gelobt
da stellen sich fragen an heute hat es
am kurs von bhp ceo von essent mir
message so etwas ja ich habe eine frage
wie zum teufel bist du so schnell in den
stuhl gekommen warten sie als chefin
weiß von der leyen garantiert seit
monaten vom absichtlich herbeigeführten
elend in den griechischen lagern jetzt
tut zu betroffen
daher kommen andererseits sie ist ja
erst knapp neun monate im amt
da läuft offiziell noch die probezeit
aber ich kann ja mal ein zwischenzeugnis
schreiben wird immer ursula erledigt
alle arbeiten mit großem fleiß und
interesse
besondere stärken zeigt sie in den
bereichen vor flugzeugen stehen mit dem
hubschrauber über flüchtlingslager
fliegen und natürlich händewaschen mit
ihren versuchen andere eu länder zur
aufnahme von flüchtlingen zu bewegen
sorgte sie in brüssel stets für große
heiterkeit frau hinterlässt ihre handys
immer sauber und aufgeräumt wir wünschen
ihr alles gute auch beruflich damit ihr
traum doch noch wahr wird
am liebsten wollte ich ballett tanzen
und zwar so ungefähr auf dem pony rücken
referierten dass er nicht antreten
wer nicht wer nicht weil der damen und
herren fünf jahre nach 2015 gibt es
immer noch keine europäische asylpolitik
es kann doch nicht wahr sein was haben
wir gemacht mit der zeit in dieser
europäischen union gilt wirklich nur
noch jeder für sich außer es gibt
frisches geld zu verteilen wir sind so
weit von einer wertegemeinschaft
entfernt da können sogar die briten
wieder mitmachen und luxemburgs
außenminister ist besonders sauer auf
österreich die leute werden gerettet sie
kommen auf die insel
dann nimmt die kommission das telefon
und fragt wer macht mit wissen sie es
sind 56 länder die mitmachen
die österreichische jugend vielleicht
dann irgendwie durch die gegend
so beseitigt österreich diese ehrwürdige
alte wald nation mit ihrem blutjungen
kanzler sebastian kurz dem erfinder des
prinzips abschreckung
ja der ist heute das wahre gesicht
europas nicht frau merkel
da war haben wir doch gerade die
eu-ratspräsidentschaft müssen uns die
anderen da nicht gehorchen wir können
europa nicht beherrschen da müssen wir
sehr aufpassen
die anderen mögen das auch gar nicht
ach so schade insgesamt ist das
politische berlin relativ zufrieden mit
sich nach der entscheidung die 1553
aufzunehmen und viele unserer politiker
betonen dabei auffällig oft ihre
christlichen werte ich hake mal direkt
nach wie das so ankommen ganz oben beim
chef also bei gott der die uns jetzt
live zugeschalteten abend ich bin jetzt
mittwochs bis freitags eine frau das
sind die neuen sender richtlinien hat
unser betriebsrat durchgeboxt ich kann
es nicht ändern und das tut mir leid
haben sie denn unsere aktuelle
flüchtlings debatte verfolgt ich sehe
sie gucken phoenix ja ehrlich gesagt
guck ich fast nur noch netflix und sky
aber bundestagsdebatten ziele schon mal
ein
aber dann als comedy das schiere ausmaß
der heuchelei deutlich jeder zweite
redner so die schlimmen bilder aus
moriya
dabei fanden die das heim nicht total
geil was die griechen daran
abschreckungs arbeit gemacht haben naja
moment cdu und csu sind schon durch und
durch christliche parteien ja und zwar
bis hoch zur kanzlerin lasst uns doch
mal über das christentum wieder reden
lass uns das doch mal mit fröhlichem
herzen verkünden wie oft machen wir denn
das ständig reden wir darüber aber
danach machen wir sachen die sind das
exakte gegenteil vom christentum die
nacker labert eiskalt von fluchtursachen
vor ort bekämpfen während ihre groko
immer mehr rüstungsgüter exportierten
jahr neuer rekord 795 milliarden
mit deutschen waffen neue flüchtlinge
schaffen
geile bortel damit das klar ist ich hab
die markenrechte an dem ganzen
christentums und deswegen ziehe ich der
cdu ab sofort den buchstaben c hat
neulich ein erzengel zum konrad adenauer
haus geschickt da besser abgeschraubt
steht jetzt bei mir
drüben im gästebad als klorollen halter
unions politiker versuchen gerade im
auftrag der wirtschaft das sogenannte
lieferketten gesetz zu verbessern
deutsche firmen möchten nämlich nicht
wirklich verantwortlich sein für die
arbeitsbedingungen ihrer lohnsklaven in
der dritten welt dass wir mal bekämpfung
von fluchtursachen stattdessen muss ich
mir aber hier so ein gesülze anhören
in dieser welt wo das starke schöne
schnelle zu erreichen sagt jesus
christus
egal wie du bist egal wie du dich fühlst
egal was du willst du bist mir genauso
viel wert und wenn ich klavier musik
laufen lasse
während die so betroffen gucke form
einer eiche vorwand man vergessen die
leute vielleicht dass ich neulich noch
ekelhafte interviews über asyl tourismus
gegeben haben das finde ich jetzt ein
bisschen hart frau gott wirklich
menschen können sich schon verändern
echt dann sagen sie das mal meinem sohn
der ist über 2000 jahre alt und wohnt
immer noch bei mir haben wir noch bringe
mein gott hätte können sie die nicht
aufnehmen um gottes willen gottes meine
damen und herren ich wollte euch nur um
ein kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye